forecasters in the united states are
warning of a potentially catastrophic
tidal surge on the gulf coast as a
result of hurricane ida the hurricane
which has now been downgraded to a
tropical storm swept ashore from the
gulf of mexico as a category 4 storm it
made landfall in the state of louisiana
before moving inland over mississippi
the entire city of new orleans was left
without power and it could be weeks
before it's restored in many places
now that the height of the storm has
passed a clearer picture is emerging of
the devastation hurricane ida left
behind
it was crazy it was scary it was really
really windy
and a lot of trees had fell yeah and
power lines they had sparks of power
lines everywhere it was horrible man i
was in the middle of it
in the middle of the eye so it wasn't
real good at all
on the same day 16 years ago hurricane
katrina devastated new orleans
as a category 4 storm ida lashed across
louisiana and mississippi with ferocious
winds that knocked out power for
hundreds of thousands of
my roof people
unlocks all my clothes my monitor my
appliance everything
right now i got nothing
for those who can't afford to move to
higher ground the damage and the loss is
always much worse rapidly rising water
chased those who couldn't evacuate up to
their attics where they called and
texted to be rescued president joe biden
has called ida a life-threatening storm
and declared louisiana a major disaster
area federal help is on its way
please know that we have thousands of
people out
right now
with high water vehicles and boats
who are doing search and rescue we have
dozens of helicopters up
louisiana's governor is asking neighbors
to look in on each other until more help
arrives
let's bring in matthew capucci here he's
a meteorologist for the washington post
and has been tracking ida from the
beginning matthew what's the damage
assessment from this storm so far
i think right now we're just finally
beginning to understand the scope of the
damage keep in mind many of these areas
are completely inaccessible there's
trees in the ground vegetation blocking
paths a lot of places near the coast are
still washed out with surge that has
made roots completely impassable so i
think it'll be a little while before we
fully understand but already more than
90 percent of new orleans completely
without power there are areas that are
just in shambles right now and not just
mobile homes well-constructed buildings
have been tattered by the wind and
decimated by surge so it's a
multi-faceted really a damaged signature
that we've seen and unfortunately it'll
take a long time to start picking up the
pieces even before folks can just get
back into new orleans without having to
worry about really danger in in their
neighborhoods
there have been warnings of a possible
catastrophic tidal surge there in the
gulf and the weather system continues to
move inland is this storm still
dangerous matthew
it is the threat right now is shifting
from damaging winds and surge near the
coast which was what first accompanied
the storms made landfall it's more a
heavy rain threat we're forecasting very
heavy rainfall across the mississippi
valley tennessee valley and parts of the
mid-atlantic too and the chance of some
tornadoes we saw multiple tornadoes in
alabama yesterday more likely today
tuesday across parts of the southeastern
u.s and then eventually wednesday in the
mid-atlantic region near washington dc
now the big issue like we said is
rainfall soils are completely saturated
the ground can't really take much more
water and we're expecting between 10 15
maybe even 25 centimeters of rain in
some places even in places that should
only see about maybe 5 10 in the entire
month so a waterlogged storm moving
northwards the ground can't take much
more of it and flash flooding will be
likely and widespread
well as you mentioned matthew ida has
knocked out power across most of new
orleans and many other places how is
that affecting disaster relief efforts
i think that's making things kind of
that much more difficult than that we're
having a tough time communicating with
folks in there we're having a tough time
getting information in and information
out i think that piece is key because
the more the national media can see
images of devastation can see and
project these pictures and these scenes
as to what's going on i think the easier
it is to effort resources there to get
folks to really care about what's going
on there and unfortunately given the
communication hurdles at this point we
just haven't seen too much out of the
area the coast guard was busy all day
yesterday surveying the damage and we're
really just starting to come into a
clearer picture as to what exactly
befell southeastern louisiana near the
coast we're seeing entire neighborhoods
that were destroyed by the surge surge
reaching two to four meters not quite as
bad as hurricane katrina but near the
coastline a very significant hurdle
those folks had to deal with but i think
it'll be a really a long time before
things get back to where the way they
were beforehand and some places will
likely forever be altered but those
communication hurdles are a biggie the
electricity a problem too you can't
really do too much if you don't have
electricity so residents who did
evacuate can't come back yet and start
cleaning up because if they come back
there's no running water there's no
electricity it's tough to find gasoline
and so all these people are displaced
and can't come home
matthew thank you so much that was
matthew capucci with the washington post